what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the crazy new events
in the boku no hero story including
deku's new power and the further
evolution of his quirk
all for one's terrifying true intentions
and the possible end of the epic war arc
that has been raging for the better part
of the past
year there is so much to discuss and
dive into so let's do it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime
pro or maybe you just haven't subscribed
yet make this the video that you
subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications it's annoying but you
really have to go through the trouble of
hitting that bell
and then selecting that option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos it's
just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will contain boku no
hero manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been
warned the previous installment of the
story left off with mr compresses
big gamble compressed decided to
sacrifice his life
in order to allow shigaraki and the
other villains to escape
from the heroes this turn of events
implied that the big battle between
heroes and villains in jakku was about
to
end because the villains were about to
retreat
i was skeptical about that because for
example toga hasn't really done anything
major except for her brief encounter
with ochako
but the latest chapter does seem to
confirm the retreat
although a bunch of twists and turns
definitely occur along the way
including deku unlocking yet another
quirk and
all for one possessing shiguraki's body
and revealing his
sinister true intentions the chapter
starts off with
deku looking like the poster boy for
2020
this has definitely been a rough year
for all of us so deku's face right here
is
absolutely hashtag relatable deku had
passed
out as a result of dobby's massive heat
wave
and when he comes too deku is worried
about shoto's well-being
after all deku loves to worry about
others even though he himself
looks like he is in horrible shape but
to be fair
shoto was just dropped by a massive
attack from dobby so deku wasn't the
only one
worried shoto is injured but thankfully
he is alive and he is
conscious in the very next moment deku
feels a sharp
pain in his head and deku concludes that
this must be another one of his hidden
quirks
this must be danger detection which had
once belonged to the fourth
one for all user this quirk seems to
basically give deku a spidey sense
the ability to sense imminent danger
before it actually occurs
this makes a lot of sense because in the
past horikoshi said
that spider-man is one of his main
inspirations in terms of what a hero
should be
and so it isn't too surprising that
horikoshi would give deku a quirk like
black whip
which allows him to move kind of like
spider-man and a quirk like danger
detection which gives him a spidey sense
with that said since this quirk is only
being revealed now
we can't say for sure whether spidey
senses are its only application
maybe this quirk can also boost deku's
other senses or something along those
lines
or maybe the quirk has some other
potentially useful applications like
seeing into the future for a few seconds
or something like that
personally i do believe that there is
more to this quirk than just a spidey
sense
because we can't forget that all might
had scribbled out some of the notes
about the fourth one for all user and
his quirk
that really makes me wonder what exactly
those notes said
and what made all might want to scribble
them out
was he afraid that if deku knew this
information he would push the quirk too
far
and hurt himself in some way does this
quirk have some sort of negative side
effects that we still don't know about
if it turns out that this quirk just
gives deku a spidey sense and warns him
about
imminent danger then let's face it it
won't be as cool as the other quirks
although it definitely will be useful in
battle but again
i personally do think that there is more
to this quirk and we are going to get
more information
sometime in the future meanwhile the
severely injured mr compress
is attempting to protect spinner and the
unconscious shigaraki from meteo
even though realistically speaking mr
compress doesn't stand a chance against
meteo in a one-on-one he does have a
plan
when the villains first arrived in jakku
on the back of machia
compress noticed that a bunch of
powerful nomu were congregating in a
location that isn't too far away
so if shigaraki can regain consciousness
even for just a moment
he could theoretically order the nomu to
come there
and help them escape compress's plan is
to buy spinner as much time as possible
in the hopes that spinner will be able
to wake shigaraki up
compress basically plans to act as a
diversion until shigaraki comes too
compress also tells spinner that he has
hidden dobby within his scarf
so when they escape dobby will escape
with them
spinner is trying different things to
wake shigaraki up and he pulls out
one of the charred disembodied hands
from shigaraki's former villain costume
he places that hand over shigeraki's
face
because he remembers shigaraki saying
that the hands help him feel
at peace and that is especially true for
the father hand
in particular so i'm assuming that
spinner wants to use the hand to snap
shigaraki
into action this actually seems to work
as shigaraki appears to wake
up he opens his eyes and his awakening
creates a huge
shockwave that blows meteo and the other
heroes back
i was thinking that chicago might be
using that air blast and radio waves
quirk combination again
something that he had also used earlier
on in this
fight and in that moment all the nomu
turned towards shigaraki at the same
time
and shigaraki appears to begin speaking
however
we quickly realize that this isn't
shigaraki at all
rather it is actually all for one who
has taken over shigeraki's body
now that shigaraki is unconscious all
for one
seems to imply that the more emotional
shigaraki becomes
the stronger all for one's hold on
shigaraki will also become
so basically the more shigaraki hates
the heroes and the hero society
the more influence all for one will be
able to exercise
over shigaraki's body all for one then
uses the radio waves quirk to send
detailed instructions to the nomu and
all the nomu instantly rush
in the direction of shigeraki the gnome
will arrive on the battlefield
grab shigaraki and spinner and begin to
make their escape
when spinner says that compress and toga
have been left behind
all for one doesn't seem too concerned
his priority is shigaraki
or more specifically shigaraki's body
and he doesn't really seem to care about
shigaraki's comrades
if anything if his friends were left to
die shigaraki would become
even more angry and this appears to be
exactly what
all for one wants all for once says that
shigaraki has been defeated by one for
all and endeavor
because his body wasn't ready to take
them on his body wasn't perfected
because the procedure was cut
short but in time shigaraki's body will
be perfected and the score
will be settled all for one wants
shigaraki to escape
and recover so that the procedure on his
body can be completed and so that he can
become as strong as possible before
fighting the heroes again this is
something that he's been trying to
convince shigaraki to do for quite a few
chapters now but shigaraki refused
to leave the battle naturally the heroes
desperately want to prevent shigeraki's
escape and they all attempt to stop him
the heroes know that if a villain this
strong and this dangerous is allowed to
get away
countless people will eventually suffer
at the hands of shigaraki
even deku who is clearly in no shape to
fight tries to use black whip through
his mouth
once again in order to restrain
shigaraki but
he fails and all for one tells daku that
they will meet again once shigaraki's
body is perfected
as all for one in chicago's body repels
deku's attack and blows him back
deku realizes something even though
shigaraki has killed a lot of people and
this is a sin that can never be forgiven
in the moment when he was being
swallowed up by all for one
shigeru's face actually looked like he
was asking for
help and that is how this insane chapter
ends
with shigaraki slash all for one spinner
and dobby
apparently escaping with the help of the
nomu at the same time
other heroes including bernin are
arriving on the scene
and the aftermath of the battle is
absolute carnage
the city of jakku has been reduced to
rubble and so many heroes and hero
students are
severely injured or worse deku
bakugou endeavor shoto and so many
others are injured
exhausted and incapacitated and even
though we don't know the full story yet
it is clear that many people both heroes
and civilians
died during this arc some died during
the destruction of the hospital like the
shield hero crust
others died during makia's destruction
of the city and
other cities that he passed through on
his way to jakku and
others died at the villain mansion now
that the dust
is settling it is clear that the hero
society will never be the same again
the heroes can't just explain away this
massive
nationwide villain attack the heroes
clearly failed to protect
the people which is their primary job
and that will have
massive consequences for the entire
world of boku no hero
once we actually have a final conclusion
for this arc i will definitely make a
video talking about the
implications of this insane war on the
future of the story
but in terms of this chapter the biggest
things that i am wondering about
is this new quirk that deku just
unlocked all for one's true intentions
for shigaraki
and what will happen to mr compress and
toga if they really are going to get
left
behind let me know what you guys think
is there more to deku's new quirk
beyond just sensing imminent danger and
why did all might cross out some of the
notes
about this quirk and its user also
did this chapter just confirmed that all
for one was manipulating shigaraki the
entire time
and trying to take over his body and use
it as a vessel
i feel like this chapter definitely
implied that all for one has just been
grooming shigaraki so that he can use
him as a vessel
that everything is for my sake instead
of everything is for your sake
was a big clue in my opinion but
in the past all for one definitely did
act fatherly towards shigaraki
so what do you guys think is shigaraki
despite being a villain
also a victim of all for one and what
will the events of this chapter
mean for the relationship between all
for one and shigaraki
finally what is going to happen with
toga and mr compress
is compressed going to die and is the
war arc really going to end without toga
actually doing anything big after all of
that buildup about her awakened quirk
i find that hard to believe but who
knows don't forget to share your
thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content right
here on the channel please leave that
like it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe just haven't subscribed yet make
this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at anime uproar big thank you to all of
our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma a
disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata the
world
a quiet respect liam thompson pate heffa
ruthean yx phoenix anime 987
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
danelle
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazotsky cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica calefon
alicia
octor bonnie parks hinokamian water the
red-haired raven florian joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint
matthew crews and anthony schreiber if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you please
consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar gives
you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you